look at the left of the screen that
splash the moment a plane crashed at
speed into pool harbor
in slow motion it becomes clear just how
terrifyingly close it came to others
somehow avoiding both the yachts in the
water and the land those who saw it say
a wing walker was standing on top just
moments before
it was just terrifying to watch that the
plane hit the water went went nose first
and then
i think the pilot and the wind walker
was submerged for about 10 seconds or so
before they uh you know managed to break
free the pilot seemed seemed very calm
as he you know swam to the rib but the
the the poor the poor girl um you know
just just screaming um but
luckily both of them
they seemed okay
apart from apart from the shock
and
luckily luckily the rib the rib was
there
miraculously both the pilot and wing
walker escaped with only minor injuries
after being pulled from the plane by a
nearby boat just seconds before it sank
then we see a lady appear young girl
here from underneath the aircraft just
the torso screaming obviously in shock
they were dragging them in to the small
boat
uh
this time the the aircraft's actually
sinking
you know i mean it was literally 30
seconds and it was well under
and we thought if they hadn't got out of
there they'd
probably i mean the worst would have
happened it was so frightening
the small aircraft was performing in the
bournemouth air festival and came down
at around four o'clock in a statement
organizers said it is a huge relief for
all those involved in the air festival
that the incident has resulted in the
display crew being removed from the
water safe and well
efforts are now being made to recover
the wreckage which is barely 10 meters
from the harbour wall
when you consider just how close this
plane came to the land when it crashed
it's remarkable not more people were
injured here because just a few meters
in from the harbour wall there are
several apartment blocks and a hotel
that would have been full of people all
of whom had a very lucky escape
it's still not known what caused the
crash but the festival organizers have
said aerial displays will continue as
planned on sunday iva bennett sky news
pool harbour